has your porn and sex addiction affected
your studies work marriage and family
relationship are you stuck with feelings
of guilt shame remorse and despair or
has your addiction progressed from
pornography to zinna well we're here to
tell you you're not alone itasca is the
place where muslim males and females
struggling with pornography addictions
can find recovery and freedom
assalamu alaikum welcome to a better
care to brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys inshallah
he's come into the scene a couple of
months ago or maybe before that or maybe
he's always been doing it i'm talking
about the youtube scene
and he's caused earthquakes i mean quite
large ones you know probably 10.7 on the
richter scale and most of it the
christian apologists and the
islamophobes and the mustard deen have
felt it they felt it so bad
that on this recent video that i watched
of three clowns
absolute clowns like you know these
typical hate preachers
coming there now a few things caught my
attention when i was watching this and i
was like wow
when i saw this i was like oh my gosh
like when you see stuff like that i was
like wow
if somebody goes to that length
to go all the way there to do what they
did which you're going to see in a
minute
i was like
they are really really scared of shaykh
mantharok
so i thought to myself anyone that is
genuinely doing what they doing for the
sake of allah
will support this channel
i want every single one of you guys to
subscribe to that channel i want every
single one of you guys to
share his videos like you've never
shared it before
he's not perfect neither am i but the
point is this
he is a big phone in their throat
watch this clip guys and in this clip
just notice the tent in the back
let's watch it and let's come back all
the muslim scholars say house is a liar
do you agree with this is not a liar and
all muslim scholars don't see that
you're lying
and muslims say that
i show you then show it to me if i show
you which house are we talking about the
hashtag
do you know what that means though i'm
telling you i'm asking you guys okay you
should ask a question let me give you an
answer hufz is a party who learned
history
you ask a question i'm giving you an
answer
took his recitation from asim do you
know who asim is i know what happened
no no you asked me a question right
answer now i'm asking you a question my
friend answer the question
answer a question you asked me all these
questions and i answered them i'm asking
you one question who's asked him
who's awesome hold on why can't you
answer my question let me complete you
can't answer it
[Music]
when you're saying that these are the
six kalima's okay i did not say that so
why why is everybody learning this look
you you're from saudia did you know in
sixth columns
where are you where are you from you're
from iran did you learn sixth grade
you're my son did you learn six
kilometers
give me the christian the bible
[Music]
let's read the words in arabic yeah john
chapter three it says this is this is
the arabic bible right
and it says it says here what john okay
hold on let me let me take that i'm not
going to
god you said allah
going to read the arabic bible john
chapter 3 verse 16. that allah loved the
world so much that he gave his only
begotten son that whoever believe on him
shall not perish but have everlasting
life
[Music]
what language is this from this is the
normal english english
now you guys saw it for yourself right
when i was watching that i am under the
impression that that is
tent and as i'm watching this and
there's these three clowns there who do
not know what the hell they're talking
about
the guy he speaks a few uh uh recites
the quran in arabic and he thinks he's
got something to hold on my friend abuja
knew arabic he's in the hellfire do you
think your arabic is going to help you
yeah
prove a point yeah you don't know
nothing you got humiliated
he wrote down the ayah the the ayah that
you wanted and he just didn't put the
dots yeah the dhamma the fatah the kasra
he didn't put those there to show you
and you are so stupid and dumb
that you thought he made a mistake
that's how
[ __ ] you are
now pull that aside because you can
watch the video and you can see how they
got humiliated and they will die now
what really catch some attention
following
the tent at the back it's not shackman's
attempt
they went and got the exact same one as
his
same table
same kind of method
with a banner saying prophet muhammed is
a false prophet or he's not the last
part or something along those lines
and i'm thinking to myself hold on a
second because i spoke to shaq with my
uh yesterday on the call
regarding some other matter which was
talking about and he was talking to me
about his disappointment and what
happened
so
and
i said to them for real and he said yeah
i said where did they come from because
they came from san diego i said are you
telling me they traveled all the way
from somewhere else far away and in
america states are far
or if you're from a different place it
is far behind to another country they
came all the way there
did they come there to talk about the
gospel
no
jesus
no
the trinity
no
the bible no his resurrection jesus
resurrection
no
his divinity
no
let me get this right they traveled all
the way from there
set up the same tent and banner just
like yours
same table
even the camera looks same yeah except
the only thing that was the same is that
they were absolute ignoramus liars and
and the brother of man is somebody
that's truthful and had some honor and
character yes
they came all the way there to do that
and he was like yeah
i was like my gosh
shackles man i don't know i haven't been
watching all your videos
but whatever you're doing these guys are
damn scared i said this is glad tidings
i mean to me i wanna be glad tidings
obviously
i'm trying to say it's good news man i
said sheikh this is brilliant because
these people have come all the way here
just to attack islam we see the same
thing in the park
they do not talk about christianity
anymore man can you imagine me as a
muslim i do not talk about tawheed the
process of sallam his seerah is life
allah's attributes all this stuff and i
all i do all my life is
talk about uh the christianity and bible
how insecure you must be and they are so
insecure that they are dying to find
mistakes in the quran or claim that the
quran has changed or
ascribed um body parts allah subhanahu
wa tala and everything just so they can
feel at ease
it's not our fault my christian friends
are making this very clear
why are you attacking us if your bible
is corrupted
we do not know the authors we don't know
if they even met jesus
your trinity doesn't make sense millions
of people in the west have left
christianity your bible is corrupted if
you have that problem why are you taking
it out on us for talking about the fact
why are you mad at us go and be mad at
your own selves
god be mad at your own selves
if your scriptures are corrupted did we
ask for them to be corrupted
that is the point so instead of being
mad go and slap yourself go home and
slap yourself
that's not our problem we're just
talking about the fact that your
scriptures are corrupted we're not
seeing in a disrespectful way we're just
seeing it it's corrupted we're telling
you the trinity doesn't make sense
why are you mad at us that you're
traveling all the way there and not only
that [ __ ] guys check this out on my left
they even made a banner about man
can you imagine somebody comes all the
way there and he makes a banner about
someone else and misquotes him and puts
a lie out there
can you imagine
so sheriff man i've spoken to you and
i'm telling you if you're watching this
again
please carry on doing what you're doing
just carry on what you're doing you have
our full support we are your brothers
we're here because a believer supports
another believer yes
this doesn't mean if somebody makes a
mistake we don't know we're here to
support you doing amazing work
carry on
carry on doing what you're doing because
these people are burning they are
burning usually you get sunburned when
the sun is out these guys are internally
getting sunburns yeah and there is no
sun
is there so
carry alhamdulillah we're here to
support you inshallah
when you're against these enemies
alhamdulillah we are here to support you
may allah bless you and to me brothers
and sisters like i said before and oh my
gosh how can i forget and i'll finish on
this i'll finish on this guess what
and link i'm going to put into the video
inshallah
utman released it today
two people two people saw that banner of
shaykh man because their their
apparently their stool is a bit further
down they saw that and as they were
walking past sheikh with man's um tower
table they said oh you know that guy we
saw your picture there like what's that
about you like famous or something and
guess what
you are there and what does allah say
the enemy's plan
and allah subhan will tell the plans and
he is the best of plans
you are aiding the dean of allah thank
god
thank god carry on carry on aiding dean
of allah because two people accepted and
took the shahada the video link is here
right at the end of the video go and
watch and enjoy it because when i'm
watching that i've got some biscuits and
i've got some tea and i'm going to have
a lovely time watching the works that
these hate preachers are doing by
causing people to come to islam
may allah bless you keep you firm as
your brothers we are behind you
inshallah in good days and bad days
inshallah may allah bless you and keep
your works firm inshallah and i ask
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to accept it
from you um i obviously don't want to
over over praise you and may allah bless
you with your nasir that you came to me
as well
and alhamdulillah with good ad
and even offering me
certain classes to attend while he means
so much to me that i have sincere people
like yourself who is in my life and can
direct me to the right way inshallah may
allah bless you it will be a pleasure
and you never know we might be doing
collabs with shaykh with man uh one day
inshallah brother sisters until next
time
let the enemies hate alhamdulillah we
have the quran we have the sunnah
alhamdulillah we have allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala and inshallah may allah accept it
from us till the day we die we defend
this kalam the kalam of allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala may allah allah accept it from
us that we die on this path assalamu
alaikum warahmatullahi